في السودان الظاهره محل جدل دائم بين
الفتيات فاستخدام السودانيات لمنتجات
التبييض ورغبتهن الدائمه في تفتيح الوانهن
باعتبار البياض رمزا للجمال يثير الجدل في
المجتمع السوداني البعض يعتبر انها تتضمن
تغييرا للهويه في حين يوضح الاطباء ان
مضاعفاتها الصحيه خطيره الهوس بالبياض لم
يقتصر على النساء فقط بل دخل الرجل
السوداني هو الاخر في مضمار البحث عن
كريمات التفتيح
[موسيقى]
احنا زمانك على الطبيعه زي ما قلت الاخضر
اخضر والاحمر احمر والاصفر والاسمر انا
اسمراني
كلمات ما عندها على الطبيعي والله يعني هي
حاجه بين كويسه وبين كعبه ممكن تستخدم
المعقول ما لدرجه ان سبب لها الامراض وكده
يعني ممكن تستخدم المعقول وتستخدم معه
مرطبات وكده انا ضد الكريمات لانه اول
حاجه بتغير
[موسيقى]
شكل الزول وانا شايفه انه الطبيعه احلى
واجمل السودان شمسنا حاره وبتعمل على
اسمرار البشره فانا
الهوس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]